after seven weeks in lockdown and a
society changed for many decades to come
today the Prime Minister will unveil his
plan to take the country into the next
stage of this crisis a new normal a new
slogan from stay home to stay alert in a
bid to control the spread of kovat 19 a
new terror style warning system - with
levels from 1 to 5 designed to help lock
down areas where the spread is too rapid
and to explain to the public what's
going on and why but anyone still
pinning their hopes on restrictions
being eased tomorrow will be
disappointed
a series of small immediate changes and
slower long-term shifts if the data
improves are far more likely so what can
we expect garden centres could reopen
and people encouraged to use open spaces
as long as they distance themselves
exercise might be allowed more than once
a day and masks could be worn on public
transport schools may be reopened slowly
although not for weeks to come whatever
changes the Prime Minister does make he
must communicate them clearly over the
weekend mixed messages have been blamed
for increasing numbers of people
floating the rules if we don't
understand why the actions are really
helping and we feel things are being
held back that will make us much less
likely to comply and so I think it's
really very important that that the
reasons are explained not even enormous
detail but the broad outlines of why why
we're making the steps as we are and and
upon some sketch what's coming next
and regional variations must be
carefully managed claims the new Terra
style warning system could lead to
stricter measures in some areas over
others have also prompted concern I can
understand that different parts of the
country may have different ways of
interpreting so here we are in a
beautiful island and obviously your
lockdown has affected us in certain ways
we can't go to the beaches we can't go
do all the things we do and if I'm in
London I'm sure there are completely
different pressures on the community
that lived there but there has to be a
consistent message across the country in
my view today mr. Johnson must balance
growing pressure to get the country and
the economy moving with the need to keep
people safe it is an unenviable
balancing act the Prime Minister must
show the nation there is light at the
end of the tunnel but there is a way to
go yet
Kate McCann Sky News